bienvenidos a enlace centroamérica a
este capítulo desde belice uno de los
países bañados por el mar caribe único
en américa central donde el idioma
oficial es el inglés por haber sido
parte de las colonias británicas país
que apenas se independizó en
1981 y es que una de las huellas
evidentes de la influencia del reino
unido- en este país es justamente su
moneda el dólar beliceño donde está
estampada la reina isabel segundo quien
fungió como su jefe de estado hasta el
día de su muerte
belice es en efecto uno de los reinos
que conforman el commonwealth cuyo
fervor por la corona británica aún se
evidencia en las calles de ciudad de
belice con el aniversario cada 10 de
septiembre de la batalla de saint
georges y el enfrentamiento con el cual
el imperio británico venció
definitivamente al espanyol en
1798 por la posesión de estas tierras
al igual que con la batalla de san
giorgio esquí donde luchamos hombro con
hombro esa fue una receta de éxito para
belice estamos aquí porque ellos
estuvieron aquí por eso tenemos el
estado de derecho el manto del reino
unido sobre belice ha significado una
importante protección en sus asuntos de
soberanía el ejemplo más claro es haber
frustrado durante décadas el reclamo de
guatemala por recuperar la mitad del
territorio beliceño que según ellos les
fue usurpado por los ingleses uy
tenemos enemigos guatemala es nuestro
enemigo así que realmente necesitamos
apoyo hasta que podamos hacerlo por
nosotros mismos así que nos quedamos con
la monarquía por ahora
bueno creo que guatemala tiene que
dejarnos en paz esto ha sido una
reclamación durante años así que ya
sabes déjanos en paz
por su ubicación en inmediaciones del
caribe belice es un país que no se ha
salvado del fuerte impacto de los
huracanes tanto así que su capital que
la ciudad de belice tuvo que ser
trasladada al interior del territorio a
la planeada urbe de belmopán
los devastadores huracanes son uno de
los argumentos del porqué belice es uno
de los países más endeudados del mundo
ocupando el puesto 170 de hecho feliz se
mantiene un déficit del 99 por ciento de
su producto interno bruto lo que
representa una deuda per cápita de
cuatro mil trescientos euros por
habitante a pesar de ello los beliceños
le apuestan al turismo como el segundo
renglón más importante de su economía
que provee empleo al 35 por ciento de su
población and then we have serbal
attractions tenemos varios atractivos
somos un país muy pequeño pero al mismo
tiempo somos un país muy diverso tenemos
deportes acuáticos buceo uno de los
mejores museos del mundo debe estar bien
bueno debe estar bien count on the world
los cayos los atolones de alta mar y la
segunda barrera de coral más biodiversa
del mundo convierten a belice en un
destino turístico para los amantes de la
playa el museo y otros deportes
subacuáticos
además del mar definitivamente tenemos
increíbles selvas tenemos bosques
tropicales y tenemos un montón de
hermosos lagos también en la parte
continental así que todo es una gran
combinación y creemos que es muy
atractivo para todos los que visitan
belice por encima del turismo que a
grosso modo sólo es aprovechado por
estadounidenses canadienses y alemanes
la agricultura es la industria que reina
en belice
paradójicamente una comunidad de
inmigrantes que apenas representa el 3%
de la población es la responsable de más
del 80 por ciento de la producción
agrícola también de más del 90% de
productos lácteos y de venta de pollos
hablamos de los menonitas
mayáns hasta mis antepasados vinieron
aquí en
1958 yo nací aquí mi esposa nació aquí
la mayoría de mis hijos nacieron aquí en
belice y estamos aquí por elección a
diferencia de muchos beliceños que
quisieran mudarse a los estados unidos
oa otros países los menonitas estamos en
belice por elección y por eso creemos
que somos más beliceños que nadie en
animales el censo de los menonitas en
belice ronda los 12 mil pocos en
comparación con los que habitan en
américa considerando que hay cerca de un
millón repartidos en países como canadá
méxico bolivia y paraguay los menonitas
de belice llegaron en
1958 tras oleadas de emigración a razón
de escapar de una persecución religiosa
y de legislaciones que les prohibía
gozar de libertad
es nuestro deber cristiano apoyar a
nuestro gobierno rezando ante dios y
realmente disfrutamos de la libertad
religiosa que nos da el estado freedom
from from de usted
las enseñanzas son todas tomadas de las
sagradas escrituras de la biblia que
creemos es inherente a la palabra de
dios sigue siendo relevante hoy en día
nos habla nos da orientación sobre cómo
vivir y también sobre cómo formar a las
futuras generaciones y generation con
los menonitas belice conforman un
complejo universo demográfico que no le
permite encasillarse en ser un país del
todo caribeño ni del todo
latinoamericano en belice confluyen los
mestizos que son los descendientes de
mayas y españoles los creoles que son
los descendientes de británicos y
africanos esclavizados los garífunas que
son la población afro del caribe y los
mayas que son los indígenas
prehispánicos
una riqueza cultural que combinada con
su riqueza natural convierten a belice
en uno de los destinos más interesantes
de américa central pero cuya imagen poco
se exporta a los países de américa
latina así terminamos este capítulo
muchas gracias por seguirnos en la
cámara estuvo nuestra periodista aurora
ayuda y recuerden que este episodio de
enlaces centroamérica lo pueden
encontrar en nuestro sitio 24 punto com
[Música]